depuis la dernière élection
présidentielle américaine la russie a
été plus souvent qu'autrement associé à
la désinformation
mais au-delà de cette incursion russe
dans le contexte américain ci est à
travers des médias tels que rt du scout
nick que moscou exerce son influence en
plusieurs langues et sur plusieurs
territoires
la journaliste les oil a été à l'emploi
de rt est ce qu'elle a vu de l'intérieur
l'a poussé à démissionner en direct dès
16h chef depuis ce début de l'équipe
tard combien de fois on a parlé de la
russie et pour cause j'ai tellement de
choses à dire notamment sur l'ingérence
politique en somme le couvert
abondamment l'on va aller ailleurs parce
que la russie est aussi un brin si on
veut de propagande à l'échelle
internationale incarnée par spoutnik et
rt21 indien coi
dans le fond c'est pas clandestins comme
l'ingérence politique c'est vraiment
ouvert donc on lit un article de russia
today ou de spoutnik on est censé savoir
que le cvc des médias qui sont financés
par le gouvernement
là où il s'est un peu moins clair ces
médias l'ont mis sur pied des gens de
médias viraux pour essayer d'atteindre
les jeunes dont des pages facebook et
twitter qui s'appelle india ou une
question mystère ou c'est pas tout à
fait clair que c'est
c'est vraiment se présenter comme des
vidéos virales style baby mais c'est
clairement s'ils sont opérés par s'est
vraiment fait pour essayer de tendre un
peu plus jeunes mais là encore ça se
sache aucun son ne laisse qu'une telle
mesure tu parlais du financement des
organes de presse la parler le pouvoir
central en russie dans quelle mesure les
liens que le kremlin se rapprocher spots
mais qui a été créée par le fils de
communication internationale marius
carrément recettes des financements de
columbus n'a été créé par l'ancien porte
parole du président vladimir poutine
donc les deux affirment deux qui sont
complètement indépendants mais quand on
regarde leur couverture vont jamais
jamais mettre le gouvernement dans
l'embarras
sahling toujours avec les intérêts les
histoires qui vont sortir vont souvent
collé aux intérêts nationaux de la
russie
la cdpm les ennemis la russie comme si
leur société s'effondraient comme ça
allait mal donc je savais exactement
donc on joue sur des clivages sociaux
qui existent déjà et qui sont là par
exemple russia today spoutnik ont fait
une couverture vraiment demeurera moeurs
des manifestations du jeu les gens par
exemple montrer comment ça va pas mieux
en france comment les gens sont pas
d'accord comme la société là bas il faut
dire aussi si on veut être équitable de
notre analyse est que d'autres pays ou
s'ils ont eu des médias semblables qui
servait les hôpitaux les mêmes objectifs
c'est vraiment pas seulement la russie
qui fait ça on peut penser al jazeera
parc par exemple qui me disait financé
par le gouvernement du qatar là aussi on
constate que de la propagande à dallas
états unis aussi longue longue tradition
des médias étatiques comme ça on pense à
vous smicards sont les médias qui sont
pour avancer les intérêts américains à
l'étranger
c'est vraiment bonne s'est pas seulement
l'âge de 6 qui braie et les russes eux
campent au style notre collègue damart
altérer ce couvent leur donna parole
n'est plus là
[Musique]
mara a choisi au lieu de nier
particulier pour nous parler la
désinformation en russie sous poutine
oui je suis sur la célèbre place
loubianka en plein centre ville de
moscou
célèbre en raison de l'immeuble qui la
domine regardez c'est le bureau du fsb
donc autrefois le kgb c'est encore ici
que ça se passe le service de la
sécurité d'état
et c'est un si beau symbole extrêmement
a pas important alexis pour tout ce qui
a trait à la désinformation parce que le
mot d information en soi c'est une
traduction emprunter virus décime
formate cia qui à l'époque de l'union
soviétique est un département
entièrement consacré à la désinformation
est encore aujourd'hui la russie sous
vladimir poutine depuis 20 ans et encore
et encore plus qu'elle ne l'était m de
la désinformation
concrètement comment ça s'est déployée
comment ça a été installé en tant que
système à l'intérieur même des
frontières de la russie
peut-être pas en tant que système et je
dirais que la clé pour le régime de
vladimir poutine ça a été d'abord un
service de télévision aux services de
l'état avec des chaînes comme la cia et
leurs équivalents du verdit vous voulez
qu'ils nient qui entretient le flou ce
qui fait qu'on a ce qu'on appelle en
anglais et retire un récit qui
s'installe où la réalité les faits sont
complètement dissous et on a une
population qui s'abreuve de nouvelles
complètement déformée et qui au fil du
temps ce sont habitués mais malgré tout
dans l'espace médiatique russe s'est
amarré ce qui existe des alternatives
bien qu'elle soit marginal pour les
russes qui veulent voir les choses
autrement
il y en a ce qu'on appelle des médias
alternatifs ou l'antidote si vous voulez
à la ligne du kremlin mais il n'y en a
pas beaucoup
ça c'est des choses qu'on voit aux états
unis vous savez il ya des médias qui se
consacrent 24 heures sur 24 aux
mensonges par exemple de drop aux états
unis et ça c'est sans risque aux états
unis de représailles est sérieuse alors
qu'ici c'est le genre d'activité qui
peut coûter la vie à des journalistes
dont le vue et sont encore le craignent
le clip de crème elle a toujours nier et
parlons b des moscovites qui tantôt des
russes en général dans quelle mesure ils
comprennent un peu ce qui est en place
c'est intéressant comme qu'elles sont
servis chaque fois que je fais un
reportage je reçois beaucoup de
commentaires sauf la russie deux pays
qui polarise 1 on aime ou on la déteste
et les gens disent voyons les russes
consomment la télévision d'état 1 les
russes ne sont pas politisés c'est pas
vrai du tout de plus en plus de jeunes
se mobilisent contre ce qu'ils
considèrent louis la propagande mais
surtout la désinformation est un exemple
assez éloquent vous savez cet été il ya
eu des manifestations monstres à moscou
pour dénoncer la décision
l'aide écarté d'entrée de jeu des
candidats indépendants aux élections
municipales et alors que le reporter de
la chaîne rassis essayait de faire son
direct pour expliquer que c'est pas vrai
que le kremlin n'avait pas écarté ces
candidats il ya des jeunes qui se sont
massés autour de mu en criant propagande
propagande
ça nous en dit beaucoup sur le fait que
ces jeunes là sont en quête
d'informations alternatives et savent
exactement comment l'état et c'est du
moins de manipuler l'opinion publique
avec beaucoup de succès depuis des
années mais le temps va nous dire
jusqu'où cette machine peut aller à
l'excès à l'étranger certainement mais
pour ce qui est de l' influence ici à
l'intérieur même de la rue si les gens
ne sont pas dupes ils savent exactement
à quoi ils ont affaire car marc altéré
sco merci infiniment prix viêt david a
nié ce geste à cinq attaquants